le chat de schrödinger c'est ce chat
hypothétique imaginé par le physicien
erwin schrödinger et qui à l'issue d'une
expérience bizarre se retrouveraient
enfermé dans une boîte en étant à la
fois mort et vivant évidemment ça paraît
impossible et d'ailleurs je creuse
dinger avait imaginé cette expérience de
pensée justement pour souligner le genre
de paradoxe auquel on s'expose si on
admet le principe de superposition
quantique et pourtant ce principe de
superposition
c'est vraiment le concept fondateur de
la mécanique quantique celui dont tout
va découler d'après ce principe un objet
quantique disons une particule pourrait
par exemple ne pas vraiment se trouvait
ici ou là mais dans une superposition
des deux positions et c'est vrai pas
seulement pour la position un objet
quantique peut se trouver dans un état
dans lequel une propriété donnée n'a pas
de valeur bien défini et peut se décrire
comme une superposition de plusieurs
valeurs alors c'est très bizarre et ce
qui est un peu agaçant c'est que on ne
peut jamais observées directement ce
genre de superposition la mécanique
quantique nous dit oui oui une particule
peut se trouver dans un état qui est une
superposition de deux positions mais si
vous cherchez à déterminer par une
expérience où se trouve la particule et
bien elle va se matérialiser soit ici
soit là donc apparemment on ne peut
jamais directement constater la
superposition à cause de ça le concept
de superposition est quand même assez
difficile à admettre et le premier
réflexe c'est d'expliquer la
superposition comme une simple ignorance
de l'état réel de la particule ce serait
plus crédible de dire que la particule
n'est pas vraiment dans un état
superposé elle est soit ici soit là mais
juste nous ne sait pas où et quand on
cherche à savoir où elle est et bien on
découvre sa position réelle mais qu'elle
avait en fait depuis le début et ben non
la mécanique quantique insiste et nous
dit que ça n'est pas ça que cette vision
n'est pas correct et que la
superposition est bien réelle pour
souligner cette différence je fais très
souvent la comparaison avec ce qui se
passe quand on joue à pile ou face si je
prends une pièce de monnaie que je la
mets dans le gobelet et que je suis
bon bah quand je soulève le gobelet
j'aurais pile une fois sur deux et fasse
une fois sur deux pour autant après
avoir éjecté le gobelet et juste avant
de le soulever on ne peut pas dire que
la pièce soit dans un état qui soit une
superposition de pile et face dire aller
soit dans l'un soit dans l'autre les
juniors lequel et je le découvre en
soulevant le gobelet après avoir agité
le gobelet on peut si on veut décrire la
pièce comme un mélange de pile et face
mais c'est une description probabiliste
qui reflète notre ignorance de la
réalité en vrai la pièce est déjà dans
l'un des deux états il n'y a pas de
véritable de superposition la
superposition et dans notre tête si vous
voulez parce qu'on n'a pas toutes les
informations est ce que nous dit la
mécanique quantique c'est que pour les
objets quantique ces différentes ça ils
peuvent être dans un état qui est
vraiment une super position par exemple
si ceci était une pièce quantique on
pourrait ajouter le modeler
et tant qu'on ne l'a pas soulever la
pièce n'est ni piles ni face mais une
superposition des deux et quand on
soulève le gobelet elle se
matérialiserait dans une des deux
configurations je sais pas ce que vous
en pensez mais à première vue ça semble
difficile à croire comme explication
d'un côté une pièce normal quand on
secoue le gobelet elle serait dans l'un
ou l'autre des deux états et on le
découvre en regardant et de l'autre côté
la pièce quantique serait dans une vraie
superpositions sauf que de toute façon
avec la pièce quantique quand on regarde
l'état se matérialiser on trouve soit
pile soit face avec une chance sur deux
a priori je vois pas bien la différence
entre les deux situations dans un pièce
normale et pièces quantique
comment on fait pour avoir la certitude
que les objets quantiques sont bien des
vrais superposition si de toute façon on
ne peut jamais observé cette
superposition qu'est-ce qui me prouve
que la notion de superposition quantique
est bien réelle ça fait un peu arnaque
en fait la mécanique quantique nous dit
oui oui les superpositions existe mais
en fait vous pourrez jamais les voir
mais croyez moi sur parole elle existe
quand même et c'est même pire que ça non
seulement à priori on a conclu une
raison d'y croire mais en plus on voit
même pas très bien quel genre
d'expérience on pourrait faire pour
prouver que c'est vrai pour se
convaincre que la superposition et réel
puisqu'on observe jamais directement et
bien aujourd'hui on va voir le genre
d'expérience qui permettent de montrer
que les état de superposition existe
vraiment et ne sont pas juste comme une
pièce à pile ou face je vais vous
décrire ses expériences de façon
stylisée mais ça donne l'idée alors
imaginer qu'un jour je viens de vous
voir avec une pièce de monnaie et un
gobelet et que je vous dise cette pièce
est spécial je peux la mettre dans un
état superposé grâce à ce gobelet et je
vais vous montrer pour ça je suis venu
avec une machine cette machine ressemble
à une boîte métallique il ya un petit
tapis roulant qui rentre et un autre qui
en ressort en entrée vous pouvez placer
une pièce recouverte d'un gobelet elle
passe à travers la machine et vous
pouvez soulevé le gobelet en sortie pour
voir comment est la pièce je vous dis
pas comment marche cette machine mais je
vous propose de faire des essais
ensemble et vous constatez la chose
suivante si vous prenez la pièce que
vous la mettez sur pile avant de la
recouvrir par le gobelet et de l'envoyer
dans la machine alors elle va ressortir
soit pile soit face à une chance sur
deux c'est à dire que si vous faites
cette expérience un grand nombre de fois
eh bien vous aurez en moyenne en sortie
50% de piles 50% de face et de même si
vous placez intentionnellement la pièce
surface en entrée et ben pareil vous
aurez en sortie 50% de piles et 50% de
face bon ok tout va bien jusqu'ici et
maintenant je vous dis on va agiter la
pièce quantique dans le gobelet
[Applaudissements]
et mettre le tout dans la machine mais
sans regarder alors votre avis qu'est ce
qui va se passer en sortie vous laisse
réfléchir
bon ça devrait pas être trop compliqué
que ce soit pile ou face en entrée on
sait que c'est 50 50 en sortie donc si
je souffre ou la pièce avant à
l'intérieur du gobelet elle est soit
pile soit face et donc on aura toujours
50 50 ans sorti peu importe le
fonctionnement interne de la machine
si on sait que ça donne 50 50 pour piles
et pareil pour face bas pour une pièce
secoué dans le gobelet il peut rien se
passer d'autre que 50 50 on est d'accord
et bien là imaginer que quand je secoue
mes pièces dans le gobelet et que je la
mets sans la regarder et bien en sortie
j'ai toujours 100% de piles
ça devrait vous paraître impossible mais
imaginez que le résultat l'expérience
bas ce soit vraiment ça je répète pile
ça donne 50 50 face à 50 50 mais secoué
dans le gobelet sans la regarder ça
donne 100% de piles j'espère que vous
voyez que ce genre de et impossible à
expliquer si on suppose que dans le
gobelet en entrée la pièce a toujours un
état bien défini si vraiment elle avait
un état bien défini il y aura pas le
choix ça devrait être 50 50 en sortie et
pas 100% de piles et pire encore
imaginer que je vous montre que la
machine possède en fait un petit
commutateur avec marc est plus moins
qu'il a été sur plus quand je le mets
sur - la machine a exactement le même
comportement qu'avant quand on place la
pièce intentionnellement sur pile ou
face c'est 50 50 ans sorti mais cette
fois on obtient 100 % de face quand on
met la pièce sans la regarder alors
j'espère que vous êtes convaincu que si
j'étais capable de faire cette
expérience là sous vos yeux ça vous
prouverait que le phénomène de
superposition est bien réelle et si vous
n'êtes pas convaincu franchement revenez
en arrière et mettez pause pour
réfléchir à comment expliquer ça
autrement les résultats je vous ai
présenté serait impossible à justifier
en disant que la pièce a toujours un
état bien définis à l'intérieur du
gobelet on ne peut donner sens à ce
résultat qu'en admettant qu après avoir
secoué la pièce est dans un état
particulier qui n'est ni exactement
piles ni exactement face et que la
machine à la capacité d'agir
différemment sur cet état superposé par
rapport aux états qui ne le sont pas
vous voyez que même si on n'est pas
capable d'observer directement la
superposition pour autant je suis
capable de mettre en évidence la
superposition indirectement par un
résultat d'expériences qui ne devrait
pas être possible si la pièce avait en
permanence un état bien défini
évidemment ce genre de chose ne se fait
pas avec des pièces de monnaie quantique
1 mais on arrive à faire des expériences
analogue avec des objets quantique comme
des particules est ce que je viens de
vous décrire c'est en fait un cas assez
épuré des expériences qu'on appelle
d'interférences quantique le principe
des interférences c'est d'appliquer à un
objet quantique une transformation qui
permet spécifiquement de mettre en
évidence les superpositions en obtenant
des résultats qu'on ne pourrait pas
avoir en supposant qu'on a toujours un
état avec des propriétés bien et finit
le terme d' interférence vous intrigue
peut-être pour désigner mon expérience à
pile ou face généralement on associe
plutôt à une expérience comme celle des
fang zhang mais c'est en fait exactement
le même principe avec les fang zhang
j'avais fait une vidéo dédiée sur le
sujet on a un motif sur l'écran qui est
sensible au fait que l'électron est
entre guillemets passé par les deux sens
à la fois un motif qui est différent de
ce qu'on a quand il passe soit par l'une
soit par l'autre dans mon expérience
avec les pièces c'est la même chose on a
dans la machine une opération de
transformation qui est sensible aux
états superposés et qui permet d'avoir
un résultat qui s'éloigne de ce qu'on
aurait sans superpositions on attendrait
50 50 mais non on obtient 100 % de piles
vous souvenez d'ailleurs qu'on a ce
petit commutateur sur ma machine qui
permet de passer de 100 % de piles à
100% de face ces deux situations sont en
gros les analogues des interférences
constructive et destructive qui explique
les franges lumineuse et sombre dans
l'expérience des fang zhang alors vous
demandez peut-être ce que c'est que ma
machine mystérieuse qui permet d'obtenir
des résultats incroyables et ce qu'elle
fait vraiment aux objets quantique pour
expliquer les résultats bizarres qu'on a
la première chose qu'il faut réaliser
c'est que en fait peu importe qu'elle
fait vraiment les détails de son
fonctionnement les résultats de
l'expérience sont impossible à expliquer
sans la possibilité de superposition
donc même sans comprendre ce que fait la
machine le résultat est là ensuite je
vous ai décrit ici une expérience assez
abstraite à un peu stylisée mais avec
n'importe quel système quantique dont il
existe deux états classique on peut en
principe construire un dispositif qui va
permettre d'obtenir ce genre de résultat
vous pouvez faire des interférences
quantique avec le spin des électrons ou
la polarisation des photos par exemple
alors pour ceux que ça intéresse et qui
connaissent un peu la mécanique
quantique je donne les détails
mathématiques dans le billet de blog qui
accompagne la vidéo en gros il suffit
d'avoir un hamiltonien dont l'opérateur
d'évolution réalise une certaine
rotation dans l'espace de l'illberg des
états et on peut faire ce genre de chose
avec n'importe quel système à deux états
au moins un principe et avec les
réglages qui vont bien on a une
transformation qui fait passer un état
propre soit pile soit face dans un état
superposé 50 50 donc on a l'impression
que la machine sokun gobelet tout
simplement mais la même transformation
fera passer l'état superposés pile plus
face dans l'état 100% pile on 100% phase
avec nos petit commutateur qui permet de
faire la transformation inverse et on
pourrait même imaginer tous les
intermédiaires voilà c'est tout pour
cette vidéo courte mais importante pour
la suite de cette série consacrée aux
fondements de la mécanique quantique car
je voulais vraiment vous montrer comment
on se convainc que les superposition
quantique sont réels et je voulais le
faire en utilisant l'expérience
minimales la plus simple la plus pure
possible on l'a dit les interférences
avec des électrons démontre déjà ça dans
un cas particulier mais le phénomène
d'interférences quantique est très
général et il peut en principe être mis
en évidence sur n'importe quel type
d'état superposés et ça donne le genre
de résultat contre intuitif qu'on a vu
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs j'aurais
l'occasion de ré utiliser mon expérience
avec la machine et la pièce quantique
dans d'autres vidéos donc j'espère que
les explications vous auront convaincu
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui
abonnez-vous ça n'est pas le cas mais tu
es la coche pour ne rien rater des
prochaines vidéos de cette série sur les
fondements de la mécanique quantique et
puis moi je vous dis à très vite pour
une nouvelle vidéo à bientôt
[Musique]